hello folks welcome to
rational science
today we're going to be talking about
temperature
on our quest to find out what uh
quantum mechanics has in store for us
we've covered uh
force mass energy and today we will look
at one of the forms of energy which is
heat
temperature what the hell is
temperature
but before we do let's get on with the
extinction segment
of our lecture and that's got to do with
human extinction
and subject matter uh related to that
subject okay
okay so here we go a fella says we do
not have democracy nor do we have a rule
by the majority
ah surprising
uh we have a republic which has
representatives
yeah
a minority who claimed to do what the
majority who voted for them want okay in
reality they take care of their own
self-interest when given a
career in government
uh yeah i guess that pretty much
summarizes uh democracy
uh you know the the greeks
especially people like plato uh they
didn't believe in democracy
i mean you know they concocted this form
of government but
uh at least plato thought it was the
worst form of government and i'm sure
socrates did as well
the worst form of government because
they saw it as the rule of the mob
you know
people who had no
idea what um
what government was all about what
handling money was all about and they
said no you're gonna let all the all
those bums
govern
no who has to rule well you have to uh
have the uh philosopher kings
and queens today right rule
uh and yeah
one thing that people are not aware of
is that um you know well you know you
vote
uh
for politicians they become the rulers
and then they allegedly rule over you
you you've selected them for you
okay but what's the issue the issue is
that
voting is not a right
you know
there's no such thing as a voting right
the right to vote
and voting is not even a privilege
okay so uh
uh neither privileged nor right
voting is whim just whim
that's all it is
it's not even a right
for the politician
for the politician
voting is a privilege receiving your
vote he comes to you and begs for your
vote please vote for me for him it's a
privilege to have your vote
for you it's whim if you want to vote
for him you vote for him otherwise you
vote for someone else or don't vote at
all
right has nothing to do in the whole
picture
voting is all right when you don't have
it
when they forbid you to vote but when
you do have it it's not a right it stops
being a right it's not even a privilege
it's just whim that's how it is and so
yeah uh what happens is when you vote
you are tacitly accepting to be ruled by
someone
and that person like this fellow says uh
you know once they get up there they're
not gonna pay attention to you i mean
they have a lot of constituents how many
do they have
uh thousands millions
you think they're going to pay attention
to each one of those that voted for them
you know you thought this person was
gonna vote i don't know uh was gonna
vote in congress for i don't know
abortion rights
and it turns out that for whatever
reason you know he he puts that on the
back burden or doesn't care about it or
votes against what you expected him to
vote for
and you say oh what a traitor he he
voted against what i wanted yeah i mean
you know that once they're up there they
do whatever they want
so there is no such thing as democracy
anywhere on the planet and there's never
has been even and i'm not talking about
the days of the kings and queens like
you know
400 500 years ago i'm talking about even
since then there's never been a
democratic country on earth once you
vote for a group of people
they're up there and they do whatever
they want so in that sense there is no
rule of the mob
rule of the people
yeah it doesn't work that way okay
people who
who rule they rule
up there according to their interests
and if it favors your interest more
power to you
that's the way it works okay
and uh this all continues he says
something else there he let me see if i
can get this thing up there let me put
it here
and he so what does he recommend he says
with blockchain technology we could
replace our corrupt republics they're
all corrupt always
so i'm not sure what why we put an
adjective such as corrupt when they've
always been corrupt in the sense that
they always rule for themselves
uh
i mean it's like
overkill to put the word corrupt
government is always corruption okay
it's it's it's very nature no sin has no
government a government that is not
corrupt
but says our corrupt republics
in the west with the direct democracy
work each taxpayer votes on each law and
regulation and tax on a blockchain
voting platform
yeah you have these narco capitalists i
call them narco caps
and they truly believe that there's a
future first for humanity and that
future is gonna be internet
and everybody's just gonna go through
the internet and vote
uh for any piece of legislation that
comes to their desk or to their phone or
whatever
and um
and then then it's going to be majority
vote you know like we're what 8 billion
people
and there's no government it's just
everybody at home saying oh there's
there's this issue
and somehow it pops into the public
light and everybody goes to their phone
and vote says yeah i would like it the
other guy says no i don't like it
will something like that ever happen
you know that's the marxist philosophy
uh people like karl marx
believed
uh that
there was gonna be this dictatorship of
the proletariat that would take us to
the one world government this
dictatorship was just what it says
dictatorship it was the workers who took
over the means of production as well as
of government
and eventually this would develop it
would evolve to a point where government
was not needed anymore it would cease to
be
and that's what these people have
reinvented
uh with their little phones they think
they're
everybody's going to get together on the
planet eight billion people just decide
from their homes uh what laws to pass
what what um
uh
how to govern essentially it's gonna be
an anarchy in that sense in the best
sense not the anarchist who throws bombs
but anarchy in the sense that there is
no government
no one rules over you but everybody has
as much power as everybody else
people think in these terms they think
that this ideal world
uh when someday will happen
and it just strikes me that uh they
think it's real in their minds it's real
that it's gonna happen and now uh i can
only give you my five cents worth and
that is
it ain't gonna happen ever there's gonna
be no such thing as this okay
uh
let me look at something here
okay
um
so no uh blockchain
everybody voting through their phone
uh
maybe in the land of the klingons
and
we're not gonna make it in fact
uh you know for whatever whatever what
little time we have left here on earth
okay
we're due for extinction so this world
in which everybody votes through their
phone
uh
yeah great ideal that's all i can tell
you
okay another issue
raises says uh east asians are really
smarter
for example they got 13 more brain size
but we uh ain't sure okay
um i looked it up to see if this is true
or what the numbers say
and uh these are the numbers i find
there was a study some years ago
it says the average cranial volume among
east asians was 1.415
cubic centimeters okay compared with one
three six two for europeans one two six
eight for africans
uh i don't know this was a racist uh
study
it sounds like it but if you do the
numbers well the asians are what is it
about uh
0.04
i'm sorry four percent
um
uh bigger brain case than whites like me
for example and almost 12 percent
uh bigger brain case than the uh
than the blacks
well
assuming it's true uh does that make
them more
intelligent smarter
because they have a bigger brain
i mean
it is uh also said that the neanderthals
they had bigger brains than ours or just
about as big as ours
were they as smart as we were
well certainly they did not develop
beyond hunter gathering we we did a
little better right that's one issue but
then you know take uh take the
guy with the biggest brain
uh in um
in the east
and you bang him over the head with a
hammer and he's got a big lump there you
know he goes all wacko on you
uh
he's got a big brain does that make him
smarter now that he's uh got this big
problem on his head then either a white
man or a black man
you know i mean i don't think that brain
size
uh is is the factor that determines
uh
if you're smart smarter or not
and you know if you look at uh just
history right you'll find that the west
did better than the east
was this because
you know they were smarter
it meaning do they have bigger brains in
those days 400 years ago 500 years ago
when the western world was way ahead of
the eastern world
and i can tell you that it's not the
case they were not smarter and they were
not
um
they probably didn't have bigger brains
than than we have today
what happened was that you know the west
for historical reasons the way things
developed
uh
you know they they did their the
countries like europe
uh did very well compared to the rest of
the world and so the rest of the world
stayed behind all these countries in
europe were coming up
and if you go a thousand years ago it
was the arabs that were up there in not
europe europe was undergoing terrible
times right after you know charlemagne
and some of the other people who ruled
europe uh whereas the
uh arabs seemed like they had the world
ahead of them you know
and it lasted maybe 600 years till about
the days of suleiman the great you know
the
the uh magnificent
and and then from then on the ottoman
empire went down and what came up with
were the europeans
so uh
were the arabs with bigger brains uh you
know a thousand years ago were the
whites in europe with the bigger brains
400 years 500 years ago and now the
chinese now are growing their brains
bigger
i don't think so i think uh smartness uh
does not necessarily mean
you know bigger brains it just means
that today we have our brains developed
because of evolutionary processes
and uh and any person on earth more or
less i can't say that any because there
are all kinds of people out there but a
great majority of people out there have
enough brains enough smartness whether
their brains are smaller or bigger
whether they are female or male whether
you're black white or yellow
they have enough smartness to understand
anything that is taught to them if god
uh
mother nature father universe the devil
whoever comes down here
were to explain to us a theory of for
example how the universe works
i think we would all pretty much
understand it we have enough smartness
enough intelligence to
understand what's being uh said to us
or the theory
so
i don't know about uh brain size in fact
i think they did a uh an analysis of
einstein's brain
and they didn't find anything unusual
so just keep that in mind
okay so there is no hard-working culture
in the western world anymore and again i
don't think it's got to do with uh
culture it's got to do with the
development i think the united states
has reach in europe
these two regions have reached their
maximum potential they've developed
maybe as far as they can
and now all you have is marginal
uh development whereas china which was
so far back
has made great strides in the last 50
years
again because they were so far back only
because of that not because china has
some special kind of people it's just
that the way history has developed on
our planet is that you know the
europeans and the americans
reach their maximum development and now
they can only progress relatively slowly
and part of that is because the
population is not increasing
as dramatically as it used to
and china uh is only catching up
and their population is also stagnating
as you know the numbers seem to indicate
and they're going to reach uh you know
some kind of leveling off as well
so
i don't know i don't think there is
uh
this thing where they're smarter
we're all smart okay we're all smart
enough to do economics we're all smart
enough to understand things and it's got
little to do with our brain cases i
think at this point we we have all the
uh developed our brains pretty much as
far as mankind will develop it we have
the intelligence to understand anything
that god wants to explain to us
okay another uh comment here
do you think china would conspire with
the us
uh to cons to concoct and release a
virus
referring to the covet virus
well i can only give you my 10 cents
worth here again uh you know the united
states is pointing fingers that china
and china pointing fingers at the united
states
there was uh this meeting i think in
august of 2019
uh military people uh meeting in wuhan
this uh supposed city in uh
china where this uh kobe thing
apparently got started and what happened
the um
chinese say that the americans the
military from the united states brought
the bug made at the you know the secret
labs there in washington they brought it
over to han and spread it out there
and the americans say the opposite they
say oh it was the chinese who started
this
uh
kogan in a lab and introduced it over
there in gohan
and
you know you have these two mafias just
pointing their fingers at each other who
do you believe well again it's opinion
there's nothing solid anywhere there
and so one of the issues is whether this
uh kovid is an artificial thing that was
made in the lab or whether
it came through the airwaves you know
nature
uh in the case of hiv you know the aids
thing
they claim it started in africa it was
maybe
hidden
in the jungles
and someone went over there and
got in touch with some monkeys with some
apes
possibly gorillas and caught it and
brought it to the world
well something like that could happen
you know that there's um this bug out
there and suddenly you come in contact
with it and suddenly it spreads
throughout the world because you are the
carrier that could happen
uh is that the case with this covet
thing uh is it that someone just picked
it up in wuhan
uh from what from the air
it was it was never caught
and suddenly it starts from nowhere and
i catch it and bring it over you know is
that the way it works or did someone
prepare this thing
and all i can tell you some of my
suspicions about it and again i i'm on
the fence i can't tell you whether this
bug is real or not can only give you
again my five cents worth here and
that's that
i would think that china and the united
states would not cooperate on such a
thing as this
and neither would iran and north korea
and cuba and all these countries that
are enemies of the united states i don't
think it
i don't think it's
uh
possible okay i don't it's possible yet
but i don't think it's likely okay
but um the question then is you have
this bug and it comes right around
the time of flu time you know this is
the flu time here at least in
in the northern part in the northern
hemisphere you know this is the winter
fall winter era you know and uh
and lots of people get colds and flus
and so on because what it's an endemic
disease that we've gotten used to and
it's periodically among us
maybe it's the weather that changes
maybe it's the pressure uh the humidity
and suddenly people get colds and they
get sick for two three weeks some people
even die they get complications
you know that's
more or less normal you know i get colds
every now and then
flu whatever okay
but
for this other bug to come in at the
right time that the
flu comes around it's kind of suspicious
that's one of the things that gets me to
think that maybe this is
you know that maybe it's not real
uh just coincidence that
these two bugs come at the same time
and that's one issue another issue is
that you know you've got um
so many strains
uh you know when when the
um what is it the um
uh
what was this the polio the polio bug
came out
you know killed some people and uh
and then
it took a long time to get a couple more
strains of polio
this uh cobia thing already has like
seven eight strains in just a short time
that makes you kind of wonder is is is
this real
or is this something that uh
the powers that be
are introducing saying oh we have a new
strain
uh maybe you need another vaccine we
need to implement more
you know mass and shots and pcr tests
and all this other stuff
and so you know it makes you kind of
wonder
is this a you know i can't blame those
people who doubt that there's this bug
out there because
their reasoning is correct you know uh
in that sense i mean i understand what
uh
the the theory of viruses
that they develop they enter the body
they do this kind of thing it sounds
like a rational theory to me not being a
doctor or whatever right that's not my
my line of work and i could i care very
little about diseases and health and all
that stuff but all i can tell you is
that it sounds like a rational theory
but then at the same time we have an
economic theory and that is that someone
is
making a killing out of this other
people are suffering
economically right
and then this happens to come at the
right time that the flu comes around we
have all these strains all of a sudden
and it turns out that because of all
these
uh strains that are out there these uh
different uh
very very very varieties or variations
uh they implement new measures
and that does make you kind of wonder
it's it is suspicious okay that's all i
can say for now uh we might have to let
it run a little while to find out uh if
something more evident
uh comes to our ears and eyes but right
now that's what i have to think that
there could be
some issue out there where these people
are manipulating
uh
the world okay someone is okay
now the other one is you know i got two
shots the last one in september and uh
you know the the booster etc and i got a
little bit sick after the second one uh
very very light very light
a little runny nose a little sneezing
and very little uh
throat you know uh my throat hurt a
little bit
uh a few days it was gone and i think it
was due to that second shot that's what
i think i don't know
um and and the question is you know some
people say well
now that you got the shot they're going
to control you like you know with a
remote control with the joystick and
they say okay bill move right move left
uh i don't think so
at best or at worst i'd say that what
they did is put a little bit of poison
water in my
shoulder right and
that's it i don't think it did anything
more than get me sick a little bit if at
all i think it was due to that but i
don't know for sure either
but other than that i don't think
they're controlling us you know with
this saying oh now you got the we we've
injected you now we can control you you
know with all these satellites and all
this stuff no
i don't think so okay
but uh some people do believe that and
they say oh they're not gonna inject me
you know um what is it the uh that movie
uh the envision of the body snatchers
more or less you know they take over
your body
i don't think so but some people do
think in those terms and they don't want
to get the shot because of something
like that
no i got the shot because i wanted to
travel in fact uh it's it's interesting
and this is also something that makes
you kind of wonder and i'll just give
you my testimony here okay i went to
iceland reykjavik and what was it may
and they put me in prison for five days
i was under quarantine in a hotel they
fed me all that stuff but i couldn't get
out
okay
and um
okay so so they tested me and i had no
the reason they put me under quarantine
i had no vaccine i i had not taken
gotten the uh vacs yet
when i came back to germany i said no
next time i'm traveling i'm going to get
the vac because i don't want to go
through all this hassle
okay so i go there uh what was it
september i got the second child and one
month earlier around august something
like that i got my first shot okay so i
had my two shots
i was ready to go okay so i'm going now
to argentina south america
and uh
what happens you know before you leave
you got to get the pcr test okay now
listen to this
this is what actually happened i'm going
to be honest here okay
so i go um and go through all this
rigmarole to try to get that pcr test
and the reason it was such a headache
was that the argentine government said
look you got to fill this form online
before you can travel to argentina
okay so i filled out the form
and whoever programmed that did such a
lousy job that you're on the first page
putting all your information there your
password number all this stuff
and then it says okay press the button
now you can go to page two okay so i go
to page two
and page two never comes up
and what it did was erase every bit of
data that i put on page one and
it
told me to start all over again
okay so that was great and i said okay
let's do it again i did it again and
again it erased the data and took me to
page one again
and it did that three times after that i
wanted to kill the programmer
okay so i said well i can't do this
because the system has a problem
it turns out that one hour later i'm not
telling you one hour later i received a
message in my email saying
you can now go to page two
one hour later you know like my plane's
flying away and they say now you can go
to page two if you want
okay
so i i did the whole thing i finally i
was able to get to page two
finish the form i printed it out just in
case i go to the airport
and they didn't ask for it
before i boarded the plane
so i get to argentina i get to buenos
aires and with my paper in my hand i
want to make sure everything was okay
and there were the authorities uh
two dollar an hour people waiting there
and they asked you questions and they
asked if i had the vaccine i said yeah
here's uh here's the backs that i got
okay
and i said i also got the pcr i said oh
no we don't we don't care about that
okay so now i leave argentina
and i come back to germany again you
know the german government says you need
the pcr test so you go you go get your
pcr test right uh they
they do it in the nose over there okay
and
you know i got the document i got my my
pcr
visa
and
i go to the airport and i present my
passport my ticket and then they say and
i say oh i also have my pcr test
and the checking agent says uh we don't
need that
okay so i come to germany i'm saying
well they're gonna ask for a year maybe
nobody asked for anything
and so the question is
here's here you can't go to a store here
you can't go to a restaurant unless you
get the the vacs
and you're certified the police are on
the street asking for this stuff you
can't even take transportation now since
a new law came into effect
unless you're revaxed or have a
pcr test
and it turns out that here i come into
the country just leave the country come
into the country
and nobody asks for anything
so i'm saying hold it what kind of
controls are people having out there
i mean the bugs are floating from
country to country nobody's controlling
that but everybody's worried if you go
to a restaurant
and say hey are you vaxxed
so
that's my experience right now i have a
lot of doubt on what's going on out
there you know is something's wrong
they're not controlling anything
and so i don't know you tell me okay
yeah yeah i got a lot of bounce
and talking about argentina here one
fella asked a question says
can you share your thoughts on what if
anything is going on with argentina and
the reason he raised that he uh pointed
me to this
um
link
and i found a fellow who
interviewed me a short while ago his
name is ed uh
dutton
uh british guy
and he talked about argentina and how
bad things are over there so this fellow
says you know what's your take on that
uh now that i was there for a couple
weeks
and all i can tell you is uh
what i think i think that uh argentina
is undergoing very terrible times
and what ed uh dutton is saying that
this is what the rest of the world can
expect what you see happening in
argentina and i'll just give you a
number so that you can see how bad
things are okay
you go with one dollar
okay and
if you exchange it with the government
they give you 95 pesos not even 100
pesos
if you go out on the street
they give you 200 pesos
okay
now i always exchange down the streets
you never exchange
officially in argentina unless you're
crazy because you're going to lose a lot
of money you've always lost money
except one time where the dollar was one
peso one dollar during a short period of
time in the 90s other than that you
never never go to argentina and
uh use your credit cards
or uh exchange money with the government
you don't do that because they're gonna
the government's gonna steal you just
blind
and people say well you can't exchange
on the streets because you don't know
what you're getting
uh i've never had any problem i never
got a single
uh
bill that was fake
and you you don't get them because they
lose their customers so so it's the
government who says who scares you and
says don't exchange on the street
because they're getting
give you fake bills
well even the in the worst of cases even
if they gave me
you know half of my bills
were fake i would still be ahead of the
government
okay because if half of my bills are
fake i still get 100 pesos
per dollar whereas the government only
gives you 95. so even if they give me
fake bills i'm ahead
and of course that never happens i never
never got fake bills on the streets and
and it just gives you an idea of how how
many uh problems they have down there uh
just to give you an idea for one dollar
you travel
like 20 minutes
now can you like 20 minutes with a taxi
for one dollar 200 pesos unbelievable
things are extremely cheap down there
and uh you know a worker makes maybe
anywhere between 200 and 300 a month
within argentina that's in in terms of
pesos they can work with that
but imagine that person would have to
travel abroad especially go to iceland
which is probably the
most expensive country in the world uh
would be able to make it
so
all the prices and salaries in argentina
are depressed and you can spread that
around in all of south america south
america is not doing very well
and what dutton was saying is that
the west is following argentina they're
going to be in the same situation as
argentina in a few years or in a short
time or whatever
they're following argentina's lead
they're going out there borrowing money
argentina owes like 50 billion dollars
and they just go to the imf and just ask
for more money and pay interest and they
just do it this over and over and over
again that's all they do
and there's no progress there's no
expansion of the economy
and so the question is is the west
following
uh the lead of countries like argentina
uh are they just creating money with no
growth
and
is that
sustainable
you know so
this is food for thought for you
i agree with dutton on this i think
argentina is in terrible shape i don't
think they're going to get out of it i
think it's one of the first countries
that is
going to go under but they won't let it
go under because what they do is just go
borrow more money and spread it around
that's all they do
and
maybe the united states is doing the
same thing europeans here the european
countries are doing the same thing
they're all just creating money
and where's the growth
you know
is this sustainable just creating money
and just keep doing this forever
is that what we can expect or is there
going to be a
collapse of the global economy
which is what i'm saying will happen
when not if but when it happens
it's the end of man
my five cents worth
okay let's move on to uh
temperature
and uh
before i can get to that let me give you
a little introduction on energy because
some people seem to have
still big problems with the word energy
they want to introduce energy at all
costs
into the discussion
and temperature has something to do with
energy so it's a good way of getting to
the word temperature by going through
energy
okay so here's uh one following he says
the following okay
gives you an idea of uh what uh these
people are thinking
before or how they use the word energy
in order to get other things done but we
have to destroy uh the word energy
before we can get there because we need
to understand the word energy if they're
going to be using this word every two
seconds we need to understand what that
is okay so if all says weight is a
measure of the pull of gravity uh by the
way this is uh part of the same thing
okay uh it's also weight and mass etc we
have weight mass energy work
force aldi and field okay all these
words are
esoteric words you know they're uh
words that mathematical physics has
invented and these people just use them
liberally without really focusing on
what is being said okay because they're
going to try to give physical
interpretations with these words okay so
this vowel says weight is a measure of
the pull of gravity on an object
okay very clear
on earth the downward force of gravity
gives an object a downward acceleration
of about 9.8 meters per second square
mass is a measure of how much matter
there is in an object
all he did
is just to cut and paste and put it up
there okay we need to answer the
questions not simply cut and paste and
say this is what mass is this is what
weight is we already have these
definitions uh by memory it's a poet
poetry you know poem that's all it is
what we need to do is answer the
questions these are the questions that
people who use the words mass and weight
have to answer so let's make sure we
understand what the issues are and what
people need to answer okay here it is
okay we have um
is mass the quantity of matter yes or no
okay these are all yes or no
questions that all religious irrational
folk need to answer right is mass the
quantity of matter does mass have
anything to do with gravity
okay does mass have anything to do with
speed
because einstein tells us that speed
changes the mass of an object okay and
does the quantity of matter change with
either gravity or with speed
and there you have the definition from
the wikipedia rest mass is an invariant
quantity okay
okay
what does invariant mean it means it
doesn't vary
when it's at rest
so what are we talking about well we're
saying that the object has so many atoms
that's what they're saying there's a
quantity of atoms that form something
which we call the rest mass
okay fine if that's the definition of
mass you cannot use it in the next
sentence which is has to do with weight
which is what they call relativistic
mass
it says is independent of
is dependent on velocity
no it can't be because if mass is the
quantity of atoms it the quantity of
atoms does not change because something
speeds up
so now they're talking about how that
thing presses up against the scale
that's known as weight not as mass and
so we have a problem because they're
calling something which is known as
weight which it has to do with gravity
with pushing on a scale and they're
confusing that or using the word mass to
define that that's where the problem
comes in so this is what people have to
answer they have to answer look are we
talking about mass or are we talking
about weight
okay
and
yeah so this is this is where we we have
a problem these are the questions that
people who use these words have to
answer they can't just continue to say
well um
i'm just going to cut and paste and tell
you that wait is this and masters that
we already have that information so
there's no need to cut and paste anymore
just answer the questions okay
okay and uh here um
file continues and says the following
says work is equal to force times
distance
the formula doesn't change because of
incline or uh
or the i guess uh
or or decline okay uh again um
it does change and
i don't take my word for it here are
three sites
that i pulled at random and they all say
the same thing yes it does change the
equation does change and here are the
equations the equation is force times
distance times the cosine of theta in
other words you're looking at the angle
the angle in which uh the thing is
moving it's not the same thing to push
something straight uh horizontally as
pushing or pushing it up a hill or down
a hill these are
different uh
you you have to perform different kind
amount of work
pushing it up
straight ahead or downwards okay
they don't why because you're helped by
gravity that's why and so you need that
angle you need to know what the angle is
and here you have another file says the
same thing okay again all these are
equations okay that
these people put out there and you can
see that this one also mentions cosine
of theta and there you see it what is
theta is the angle between the vectors
force and displacement way down at the
bottom so you need that angle okay
and
here's the third one okay
if i get it here okay and this is from
the wikipedia okay let me get myself
back in here
okay uh this is from the wikipedia and
again it says the uh
force times distance times the cosine
okay you need that cosine in there if
you're going to push up a hill or down a
hill so no the equation is not force
equal force times distance is force
times distance times theta now theta
um
is an angle zero then uh
it comes down to one and so you have
then it be it defaults to force times
distance so uh don't listen to the
swallow because you
you're gonna be misled into
you know how the equation is you know
about
the factor known as gravity that
influences an um an object that is being
pushed okay
gravity does have an effect on that and
so you know the equation really is with
a cosine not without it
just be aware of that okay moving on
here let me get this out
well it says
energy
now we get the energy energy the
capacity defines it as the capacity okay
the definition capacity did the work is
what conceptual it's a concept right
there is no physical object called
capacity okay capacity is uh a concept
okay no standalone physical object
called capacity okay but then the small
continuous says energy starts the car
not the gas
so gas does not start your car what
starts it is this concept called
capacity
and so capacity is what starts your car
not the gas
this is where people repeat
uh without even thinking
these words have been shoved so much
into their heads that they just parrot
them just say it oh the energy that i
have and you know they use words of
ordinary speech or or notions of
ordinary speech and introduce him into
physics no no hopefully in physics it's
gas that starts your car and not this
uh concept called capacity which he
admits is a concept okay
and uh but he you know chases his tail
around he said we don't start the car
with thoughts ideas right you're right
and abstract conceptual is thoughts or
ideas correct
and so you don't start a car with
concepts such as energy because energy
as you said is a concept okay
and again all this comes down to
big definition the word object that
destroys all their arguments once you
define the word object all these
religions go down the drain and they
hate it they hit it because they're you
know they've been educated and they have
all these theories based on these words
and suddenly you say well that's not an
object you can't use it for a physical
interpretation
and it just kills them it just kills all
their theories right there and then
because whatever they say whatever comes
out of their mouth is irrational
and so yeah they have a problem with
that
okay and um yeah how it says here
it says we literally use 25 different
energies
meaning that energy is not a physical
object and yeah here you see uh if you
look it up in the wikipedia you'll find
all of these all these little ghosts you
have mechanical energy and gravitational
energy and magnetic ionization
chemical then you have the rest rest
energy that's uh
that's energy when
when you have rest mass quantity of
matter okay
uh chromodynamic energy nuclear energy
well you have all these different kinds
of energies
and today we're going to look at the one
of those at the bottom known as radiant
energy because that's going to be the
one that's going to create the heat the
temperature okay so we're going to look
at that radiant energy that these people
talk about
okay
and we'll get to that in a second here
but
anyways i just want you to know there's
many kinds of energies like saying
flavors or maybe colors
the crayon
is an object but the colors of all these
crayons
is not an object so if there are many
energies
clearly energy is not a physical object
again okay because you have all these
kinds of energy mechanical and
potential and kinetic and whatever uh
obviously energy is like an adjective
it's a type
and not a thing in itself
okay so yeah all these people have been
brainwashed in high school maybe in
college to think of energy as a thing
and they just took it for granted nobody
even challenged that
and it's only when you put them against
the wall that they realize that the
mathematicians have created this concept
and turned it into an object because
they give all the physical
interpretations using the word energy
and people just use this word you know
like the word spirit in traditional
religions and and they just keep talking
about energy what is this energy what is
the singing
please draw it i want to see it
okay so let's review
uh some of these uh things that
uh i just mentioned here uh primarily
related to energy but it says energy is
the catch-all word of math business yeah
that's what it is they use it for
everything whenever you want to fill in
a blank you know in poker or not so much
in poker but in rummy and whatever you
have this joker and you can put it as
any word any uh card in there well this
is more or less what uh
what the word energy is it's a it's a
joker
in every sense of the word
you can use it as any card you want
that's the problem with the word energy
because whenever you don't know
something you just say energy and you
filled in the blank
that's the problem
and what did we learn when we use the
word energy in fact it probably hides
more than what it reveals
and no standalone object called energy
energy is the capacity and yeah we have
all these energies uh
when it's treated as an object what
you're doing is essentially saying
spirit the spirit
my car runs with a spirit
that's what this first person said
yeah
yeah i believe it energy uh according to
mathematical physics is equal to mass
times one of those two either velocity
or the speed of light squared right
uh which one is it is it the velocity or
the speed
and that takes us to what i covered a
couple weeks ago where you have the
velocity
is um
uh
when it changes like when you have uh
angular momentum right speed straight
line no problem but velocity is no
problem when it's in a straight line but
when you turn a corner now now you've uh
had to accelerate
and the way they fixed that is saying
well the speed did not change what
changed was the um
direction
and so direction is a qualitative
concept it's not a numerical concept
therefore they say well you have
acceleration without
an increase in speed
and so it's important because uh
i'll tell you what because you know when
when uh einstein says that you have
warped space and you have this little
photon that's going at 300 000
kilometers per second in the vacuum and
now it's going to go around the sun
it's going to turn a corner
it's going to change direction
did it change its speed
do we have a different value
than 300 000 kilometers per second
and they say no the speed remained the
same what changed was the direction
okay because it's space that warped it
uh warped the path of that photon that's
the notion they have and yeah it has
acceleration but not because of speed
but rather because of
a change in direction that's the notion
they have in mathematical physics and
that's important because again
they're using acceleration to explain
acceleration why because you have
centripetal
towards the towards the center of the
object right where the center of gravity
in this case
and
what is that
centripetal what centripetal
acceleration to explain why
this thing changed direction
accelerated
but not because it changes speed
when it changes its direction why
because you have centripetal
acceleration so we have acceleration to
explain acceleration to explain
acceleration great that's the way the
mathematicians fix this
anyways uh there you have a little a
acceleration and
again no change in speed it's changing
direction that's how they fix that
um
we're not talking really about direct um
distance we're talking about distance
traveled again i covered that the other
day uh distance the separation between
two objects that belongs to physics
whereas distance traveled is by one
object okay
and so it's distance traveled it's very
different than distance of physics
and then force uh there's only two types
of forces push and pull
and what is not either push or pull is
tension
tension
no one wins the tug of war and that
contradicts the definition of force
which
someone does win the tug of war okay so
all these things keep those in mind
that's in general what i've covered you
can go back and look at some of the
videos and they'll bring you up to speed
on what the arguments are in more detail
okay okay meanwhile here we have uh
electromagnetic radiation we're going to
talk about temperature today and this is
how it starts and again it's going to be
related to energy
energy this spirit this ghost okay and
this is going to be a radiation energy
okay it consists of waves of the
electromagnetic
field
what the hell is a field
and i always like to say field is where
the cows poop that we all understand
that field okay but this field is what
you see there all these little vectors
as they're known these little arrows
that you see they're blue and red
and what do those represent well they
represent magnitude and direction
the arrow that's why the arrowhead is
there right
represents direction but the height of
each one of those arrows
is
representing a numerical value
okay so
if you look at those blue arrows there
for example the
first little loop there you get four
arrows right you see short arrows bigger
arrows bigger arrow and smaller arrow
right well the smaller arrows represent
a smaller magnitude and the bigger
arrows represent
a bigger magnitude that's what they're
saying okay and you got to think of this
in dynamic terms like the wave is
increasing or the field is increasing
and then it dies down
okay
let me say that again it's going to be
important okay
the field is increasing and then it dies
down the field increases then dies down
that's what they're saying okay
well it seems like
something that's turning you know like
um
if you look at the blue one here okay
well the field is increasing as you go
from here to there right because see
it's fatter in the center and as you get
to the edges
right it gets thinner you can see uh
like let me get it here okay
there okay
you can see what happens as you twist
this thing around okay
okay this is what they're saying they're
saying that if you look at just the
center here what's happening suddenly
disappears from you and it becomes
flatter
okay and here you see more of the blue
here you see less of the blue so the
magnitude goes to zero at some point and
here it's at maximum
well it looks like they're talking about
a rope
okay maybe this uh vector thingy is just
a rope that's torquing could it be
okay
and yeah it says linearly polarized
sinusoidal uh electromagnetic wave
propagating in the direction through a
medium
such as the vacuum
the vacuum is a medium
what is a medium in mathematical physics
i thought vacuum was nothing
space
boy
and now they're saying it's a medium
so the nothing suddenly becomes a medium
that's strange that's weird but it says
uh the electric field right
oscillates yeah here it is if the blue
one
yeah i think the blue one is the
electric one i'm not sure right now but
if the blue one
oscillates what do you mean i'll say is
this what it's doing
see here you have
zero electric field and here you have
maximum electric field
it's oscillating right and the same goes
for the magnetic field the red one
okay so what we have is uh maybe we're
staring at that all those vectors going
to zero it's just something turning
in situ
okay
i mean i can just as well
mimic that with a rope okay
okay um here we have
the dynamic version of that okay
same thing but see they they show it
going straight and the thing increasing
and decreasing you can see that's all
they're showing that it increases and
decreases
maybe what they should have done is uh
twirled it around like i did with a rope
and maybe that's a better representation
of what they're trying to uh illustrate
there okay it says the electromagnetic
waves can be imagined as a self
propagating transverse oscillating wave
of electric and magnetic fields
well the first problem is field there's
no physical object called field because
a field is just a bunch of vectors and
all that has to do with math and not
with physics that's the first issue the
second one is if it goes to
maximum and then down to zero maybe what
we're talking about something twirling
in situ in place
okay so
this is what uh the argument is going to
be okay
and of course if we're going to relate
that directly to temperature
let's continue here uh we have this
situation here the definition of the
word temperature what is temperature you
look it up uh this from the wikipedia
says a physical quantity
a physical quantity
i thought uh physical you know under our
definition physical is the same thing as
an object physical is that which has
shape that's what physical means in
physics okay so all these words thing
object physical body substance entity
they all mean the same thing exactly the
same thing they're all synonyms perfect
synonyms what is it that which has shape
and quantity doesn't doesn't have shape
i don't know any quantity that has shape
quantity is a concept
and so you either have concept or you
have objects
okay so quantity physical quantity is a
an oxymoron okay okay but let's continue
it says express is hot meaning heat
right and cold that's what temperature
does and then what does temperature also
have the manifestation of thermal energy
that's what temperature is manifestation
of thermal energy even though the word
thermal means temperature okay great
what is energy the capacity remember so
it's the manifestation of thermal
capacity
that's what temperature is
okay
the source of the occurrence
of heat right is matter
what is matter
any substance that has mass
what is mass quantity of matter
[Laughter]
uh chasing the tail around heat the flow
of energy and at that point i guess you
have to
pass go and collect 200 and go
back to energy and start all over
you know it sounds like the
argentine uh
pcr test
you go
in a circle
okay so yeah this is what you get
i mean you know what do we have here
energy has something to do with heat
heat has to do with matter matter is the
amount of mass
or the
something that has mass what is mass the
quantity of matter and what is heat
energy and then you go back to energy
and start all over and say oh what is it
okay
so all they did was go around in circles
we haven't learned anything with all
this these words that mathematical
physicists use certainly we cannot
relate it to anything physical
which is what we do here we do physics
here we don't do math we don't care
about math we want to understand how
this universe works we need the
mechanisms of how mother nature does her
stuff out there
okay so here we go with temperature
um
they say it's related to the vibration
of molecules or atoms or whatever the
substance is made of okay if matter is
heated its temperature rises more and
more okay it can be seen that the
particles contained in it move ever
faster
okay no problem there uh we're saying
that the
molecules atoms if you want whatever the
substance is made of is vibrating faster
why is it vibrating faster what is
what
physical object thing physical right
what thing is making the molecule move
faster that's what we want to understand
we're going to do physics here we can't
say well it just does and here's the
equation we don't care about that we
want to know what physical object comes
in contact with each
one
of those particles
and it turns out that you know when
when if you see it there right uh when
you look at that you see that all these
atoms or molecules whatever those are
they're all connected by a little line
there i i
i i hope i'm not the only one seeing
some lines there do you see the lines
connecting the balls all of them 100 of
them
what are those lines
uh i looked it up in the
standard model and i couldn't find lines
so i don't know what those lines are
yeah we all understand that if you move
you know if if you have two
let's let me move that
for a second out of there
you have this situation right
uh two atoms bound by
something that
you know uh unites them that binds them
that connects them and this one moves
one of them like the one on the right
here moves back and forth this one's
gonna move probably
in some way because of that that we can
all understand
now try to do it this way without the
thing that interconnects them okay so
when i move this one why would this one
move
see it doesn't move but here
if i'm holding tight and that's that
thing is straight in fact it's better to
do it with my magic wand here okay
because that's fixed okay so if this guy
moves that way this one has no choice
but to follow okay so this is the one
i'm gonna move okay i'm gonna move it to
my right and if i'm holding on to it
it's gonna pull we we all understand
that and vice versa if i pull on this
one this one's gonna move
but without that thing in between
you know i can move this one and doesn't
affect this one at all
so yeah the question that we have is
what are those let me put this back in
there what are those little lines that
they put between those alleged atoms or
molecules what are those lines
see they put those things you say well
yeah i understand that yeah but you
understand it but that's because they
put it there by hand what are those
little lines can we can can you identify
those uh things because obviously it's a
thing
it's got at least two dimensions i would
say maybe three
okay
so you gotta identify those lines that's
the issue
okay and so this takes us to the
spectrum because
they say that what that is has something
to do with frequency
the freak of what what freak is this
okay and here it is frequency is
directly proportional to the average
velocity of molecules
okay so that means if you increase the
frequency you're going to increase the
average velocity of molecules
the
higher the frequency the hotter it is
the you know the lower the frequency the
colder it is
okay but what is this frequency the
frequency of what is the question okay
this is what we want to understand we
understand the physics of this okay so
yeah we see that and here you see
another version of that essentially
there you see it it's the frequency of
light of this electric and magnetic
fields okay
and again what are we staring at we're
looking at a bunch of vectors okay
some are moving faster the one is on the
top and those are identified as heat or
hotter and those are on the bottom
moving slower and those are identified
with something that is cold
okay great but what are those vectors
what are those uh arrows well again it's
a bunch of arrows that form the
so-called
fields and those vectors are just
magnitude and direction
magnitude and direction of what
what is it that we're talking about what
is this frequency the the the the thing
that
is going to move the molecules the atoms
or whatever that forms a substance that
is heated up
we need to figure out what the objects
are
the things that are moving the molecules
this is the issue
and uh so far we haven't learned
anything about
the physics of it we've learned a lot of
math you know uh frequency yeah great
and what is frequency was a bunch of
vectors that move yeah that's the field
etc all these are concepts we still
don't understand what is moving this
thing we call a molecule this thing we
call an atom what is moving it and what
are those little lines that unite two
atoms
okay because yeah if you put the lines
in there you can understand why one
shakes the other one but what is that
line is that just put in there to
fool you into believing
that uh one atom is moving the other one
physically because there's something
connecting them yeah we can all
understand that if if that thing is real
but what is that they don't identify
that they identify the balls that you
see there which are supposedly the atoms
or the molecules but they never
identified the little connection there
what is that frequency is that a field
is that light is that electricity
magnetism what is that little line
okay that's what we need to get down to
we need to identify that little line
okay and so here we go
this is what uh
a
so-called electromagnetic wave looks
like
uh maybe the red one is um
electric field and the blue one is
magnetic field or maybe it's the other
way around it doesn't really matter just
color codes okay but what you're seeing
here if you stare at it a little while
you'll find out that the blue one is
kind of moving around that's going to to
values of zero and then increasing to uh
bigger values and the same with the red
one you would think that the
when it goes down when it goes down to a
zero what you're actually doing is just
twirling something around i mean doesn't
that look more or less like this one
here you see them again
you'll see what happens here
give it a second
you'll see what happens uh
if we turn this into something else
doesn't that look like that
when you're
just twirling a rope
and here it is again
yeah
doesn't look like it's just torquing in
place that's all we're having that's all
we're seeing there
okay
so
here you see them uh
one compared against the other so that
you get an idea
give me a second
here okay here you have let me remove
this one out of here
okay there you have it
isn't that what you're seeing
it's not that it goes in one direction
or in the other it's just twirling in
place
okay we have a
representation
uh using the rope for what these people
call a wave
transverse wave electro
electric and magnetic fields we say it's
electric and magnetic threads
okay
two threads yeah
two threads that form a rope they're
physical if we're going to do physics
right because otherwise you're doing
math those vectors that's not physics
that's math
their magnitude and direction
so um
yeah
we can have uh the same
mechanism that we've had for the last
100 or so years 150 years
uh the
famous transverse wave the one that uh
james maxwell
described mathematically
and we can just as well replace that
with a rope and get the same result
okay so we don't need these so-called
fields whatever fields are okay we don't
need these vectors whatever vectors are
magnitude and directions only
no physical object just magnitude and
direction
those are mathematical descriptions
and yeah when you put the uh rope in
there now you can see
why you know uh this is true here the
velocity of light is equal to frequency
times wavelength
okay and one
exchanges with the other
the more you have
the the more you torque it okay
the more links you have for the same
amount of
rope
okay so here for that same amount of
rope you have fewer links and each link
is longer which is what you see there
and now here you have more links and
each link is shorter that's what that
equation says and yeah now we can relate
it to temperature because we can say
look
the uh longer the link
what we call the link length not the
wavelength but the link length
the longer it is the colder the
substance and the more torques you have
in other words high frequency as they
call it
lots of um
links each link being smaller shorter
now you have a higher temperature
so the this temperature thingy
uh
you know um
we can relate to the rope because now we
can say well yeah if you have a higher
frequency like in the one on the bottom
the uh
the links are shorter so that thing is
moving
quite fast in other words one lump one
uh little goosebump of those
hits
the uh atom
much faster than the one on the top the
one on the one top is moving
slower in in the sense that each link
that arrives or that makes contact with
an atom
does not do it at the same rate as the
one on the bottom
and now we can see why that would
vibrate
the atom in a lattice
much uh
faster than if you have a a longer link
so it's uh
it's it's a this is from a physical
point of view you can now explain this
okay you can explain why
uh this molecule or this atom whichever
the two because again all molecules are
interconnected with this rope you can
understand that you know if you have
this
and this is talking remember all this is
at the speed of light it's very
extremely fast okay compared to what we
have in our
macro world okay so if you have this
situation you can see why uh this would
be hotter than something that is like
this you know undone completely
and that's going to be a cold
um
influence in other words a
slow influence on an atom compared to
this one okay because this is a higher
frequency higher more lumps more links
[Music]
per per unit of time or distance
so this is the issue the issue is that
one is uh going to give you more um
impetus uh more uh
impacts on an atom than the one that's
got the longer link and that would
explain temperature whereas you know in
the case of uh mathematical physics what
is what physical object is coming in
contact
with the atom
and they draw those links they they put
the little line which is this okay
we have something we put a rope in there
what are they going to put in there are
they going to put a vector they're going
to put a field are they going to put a
light
what physical object are they going to
put between two atoms what are those
lines that form
part of the crystal structure of
you know for example a rock or or
whatever quartz
what are those lines
and they never they never identify those
they might say it's a
hydrogen bond
what is a bond
what do you mean a bond
like james bond or what i mean what is
this bond
is it a physical is it an icicle
a string what is it
and
that's when they move to mathematics
they try to explain it mathematically
they just say well this is how it
influences it's a vector or or
who knows what what word uh esoteric
word they put in there to fill in the
blank now you have to identify the
physical object we're saying the object
is
a rope that interconnects any two atoms
uh the
rope does have links which is what these
people call um link
i'm sorry wavelength we call it link
length uh more links that's frequency
and now you can explain why one atom can
influence another one and turn it into
something hot
right because you have these higher
frequency or
more links
uh
getting to that atom than another
influence another
uh
rope that could be have elongated
links
that's that's the difference between
them and so yeah again we we have a
physical mechanism whereas mathematical
physics does not that's what it comes
down to
okay uh we're going to go now into
uh some of the questions people ask lots
of questions regarding what an object is
and again the word
what's my saying
the word object destroys all religions
and people have big problems with my
definition of the word object because
their religion dies
and of course they never attack the
definition they try to but their
arguments all fall flat and here are
some of the arguments that they raise so
you can have a little
fun with them here they are okay here's
the first uh first person says you're
calling this red concept an object
he's saying a thread is a concept
this invisible intangible thread is an
object
all threads are objects so here's the
answer okay to follow
you have to learn the basics okay thread
is always an object invisibility
intangibility have nothing to do with
why a thread is an object
think of a sewing thread is it an object
or a concept
why is it an object why is it a concept
i mean you got to define the word object
and concept the category so that we know
what you're talking about you can't just
say
oh
it's intangible and you call it an
object
what's an object you got to define the
word object and you've got to defend
your definition
again you can't
go out there and use authority you can't
say well it's tradition you can't use
any of those arguments
do you know of any sewing thread that
doesn't have shape
i mean
you know if it has shape it's an object
it's got nothing to do with invisibility
or intangibility and not because you
can't see your touchy table does the
table become a concept i mean if you
can't see the table that the chain man
has on the other side of the planet does
that table become a concept just because
you can't see or touch it
in other words this person raises
something that is totally irrational
okay and so uh these arguments uh
obviously destroy his his argument his
notion of what an object is
and here raises another issue okay says
you're calling electromagnetic concept
absolutely
you say electromagnetism isn't an object
correct
but this invisible intangible thread is
an object yeah and so here we um
we see the argument the answer to this
yes exactly electromagnetic is an
adjective no such physical object called
electromagnetic an adjective is a
qualifier of a noun all adjectives are
concepts
do you know of any adjective that is an
object do you know any adjective that
has shape okay so please mention
an adjective that you believe has shaped
and then you end the discussion very
simple you get a beer
okay another
question raise or issue a raise
fella says
what is this oxymoronic invisible
intangible physical mechanism thread
made of
[Laughter]
okay let's find out what it's made out
of it's made of this here it is
it's over here give me a second here
it's an irrational question okay the
single thread is an elementary entity an
elementary entity is one which is not
comprised of anything smaller okay there
you see it from the wikipedia it says
elementary or fundamental particle
because they deal with particles a
subatomic particle that is not composed
of other particles
so it's irrational to say what is an
elementary particle made of because
they're telling you that it's one that
it by definition is not comprised of
anything else
now
these people have mental problems
because they don't even understand what
they're reading there okay so let me
repeat an elementary particle is one
that is not comprised of anything
okay it's the that's where the buck
stops that elementary particle makes
everything makes up everything else
okay and that's what the single thread
is it's an elementary entity
okay so the assumption is that there is
an elementary entity that constitutes
all matter should be the same for
anything okay again
is this uh
definition of the word object that
destroys all these people's religions
they are irrational individuals and they
have irrational
theories and of course when you define
the word object they say no no no but i
don't like that definition because
you destroy my religion yeah no kid
okay here's another philosopher's
many objects take up the take the shape
of its container these don't have
defining shape
so what
i mean you know does it have shape or
not it's not a question of what is the
shape of it's a question does
it have shape it's a yes or no type of
question okay
whether an object is molded by its
container is irrelevant definition does
not require specific shape
okay
anything made of atoms had better have
shape
i hope people understand that if it's
made out of atoms it's got shape i don't
care what the shape is it could be a gas
that takes the shape of a given
container no biggie no problem we don't
care the point is the gas has shape it's
finite in its extent because the last
molecule the last atom is right there
where you can
see it or if you could see it right if
you had god's eyes
all gases and liquids have shape
meriology what an object is made of is
unscientific
is an unscientific definition of the
term known as object a thing okay
so yeah those are the answers here we
have another one
paul says again all these related to
object okay here it is
says i could say objects are that which
doesn't have shape and be just as
correct as saying objects are that which
has shape okay an object is 3d spatial
which we can see and touch
like detect measuring using technology
right and shape literally has nothing to
do with defining objects
okay that's what he says so what are the
uh answers well there we have it
unsubstantiated statements all he said
is i don't like your definition he
hasn't justified
why what you know he hasn't defended his
position he just made statements
unsubstantiated statements
uh
so you get an f or flunked
what arguments do you propo uh
support those uh baseless arguments okay
that's that's the question is and uh all
you said so far is that you don't like
the definition because it destroys your
religion okay what do you mean you could
say that an object is that which doesn't
have shape
what's the justification for that that's
just your opinion your statement
whereas you know we're not making a uh
an opinion we're giving you a definition
we're not saying you have to like it
we're saying this is the definition and
we defend it because we're saying that
all objects in the universe have shape
okay and not all objects can be seen or
touched now you gotta answer that yeah
you either
defend the somehow the seed touch
criteria
and attack the shape
how i don't know that's that's your
responsibility but
if all objects have shape and not all
objects can be seen or touched we're
done
you lost
what can i tell you you have no way of
contradicting that okay you have no
arguments against it and you can't bring
arguments of authority
of uh
of uh democracy everybody voting and
saying well we have majority over here
we don't care about science doesn't care
about that in fact that's the other way
around usually it's the fewer people who
create revolutions not the masses masses
just follow okay
like you follow these fellows who came
up with all that nonsense of see and
touch
okay there are many shapes that aren't
objects
and many objects that don't have shape
i don't know name one i mean uh but
here's my answer okay
uh until you define objects we have no
idea what that word means to you okay so
you need to define the word object and
defend your definition you can't use
arguments of traditional authority of
democracy and name one object just one
object that doesn't have shape
and i'll buy you a beer okay i promise
if you can name one object that doesn't
have shape it's one that i'm not aware
of maybe not on this planet maybe it's
on your planet over there in the land of
lululand okay
yeah i don't know of any object that
does not have shape but if you know of
one please mention it put it down very
simple because i'm saying it's a
universal property all objects have
shape
okay and so uh
the ball is in your court
okay another issue is related again you
can treat groups of objects as objects
themselves and a k uh table is no more a
true object than a flock or a pair or a
hundred cars okay uh
again mariology okay the ensemble is a
concept not an object correct you're
totally right we we we've said that many
times you have the word forest
forest is not an object it's a bunch of
trees
that's what the word forest means
now uh the kid
in kindergarten he paints a forest maybe
just puts
painted green a region and the teacher
says well what is that green stuff and
he says the forest
he's treating the whole
thing as an object
you're not supposed to think of it as a
bunch of trees you're supposed to think
of it as a region which we'll call
forest only in that sense can you say
the word forest represents an object
because you can point to that whole
thing and that thing is called forest
but if you go in there and say what is
the forest made of it's made out of
trees ah then now we're not talking any
longer about an object now we're talking
about a concept and the same with for
example a loaf of bread loaf is is a
single
thing if you say loaf and you point to
it and say instead of bread you say loaf
that's fine
loaf refers to that object but if you're
going to cut it up in pieces and say
well the loaf is made of many slices now
you're not talking about an object so
the context is very important here okay
you can't you can't
keep switching context
okay
an object is made of a single piece for
the purposes of physics when you point
to a table you're not thinking of oh
it's got four legs and it's got one top
and no no
you're pointing in your same table the
word table represents the whole object
as if it were made of a single piece you
don't say well how many atoms does it
have how many molecules how many
legs
you don't go with all that you point and
you name the whole object and that's how
you treat gases you say air you point to
the air in a balloon you say air
and that air there is a physical object
it's made out of atoms it got shaped it
had better be a physical object okay by
definition
now if you don't like the definition
your job is very simple you have to
start by
providing an alternative one we can sink
our teeth into
because we can't do physics without an
object
you can't do
mechanisms without an object
so i know it hurts but you got to come
up with a definition before you
challenge
you got to say look this is my
definition of object defend it
and then we can compare notes you know i
bring my
that which is shape that which has shape
and you bring yours whatever definition
you've got let's see who who stands in
the in the uh ring
who remains alive in the ring okay
that's the way it works okay you got to
have a good mousetrap to beat the shape
definition of object and yes the
definition of object destroys all
religions no doubt in my mind about that
one
okay one ball says if one thread
connects the pencil to every atom in the
universe wouldn't the pencil fall
in every direction
well again this apparently hasn't taken
a minimum of mathematical physics he
should maybe when he gets to high school
i don't know i mean he's in kindergarten
right now but yeah
obviously you got to take a little bit
of mathematical physics to understand
why that's not the case and here it is
okay you have um
it's an irrational conclusion you have
distance okay remember you get distance
squared there at the bottom the
denominator okay the moon has many atoms
but it is far away now it's the issue of
distance so your pen is closer to the
earth
much closer than it is to the moon so
even if the moon were bigger than the
earth
it would still be overruled by the
distance okay because distance is a very
important
uh parameter in that equation
meaning distance separation not distance
traveled okay and then you have max
principle you have stars there
and you know stars all the each one of
those stars certainly is much bigger
than the moon
but they're so far away that even the
moon pulls on the pen more than
those stars do why because of that d
squared uh in the denominator okay so
the distance is very important if that
distance is is
the separation
between the pen
and the star
is much much much
greater than the distance between the
pen and the moon well that denominator
just kills your whole numerator i mean
you're going to get a number this small
that's how uh what the tension is going
to be it's going to be very small
okay that's what the t stands for
tension
okay so i think it's straightforward
distance is very important
meaning separation is very important if
you're far away of course the ropes
are going to
you know
come together as if a single thread a
single coaxial
whereas if the object is close to you
well the ropes come from an angle
and yeah the the tug of gravity then or
the acceleration of gravity is much
greater
okay another file says
you usually your usual tactic of
deflecting the merit of questions by
obfuscating
definition of object is simultaneously
refer to parts and hole yeah see uh this
is another mariology guy okay two orbs
don't touch because their surfaces only
share a single location
okay when two gady style threads
elementary objects intersect their
surfaces such as in electromagnetic
interactions what keeps them from fusing
c touch c touch c
touch uh that's a that's all they know
how to say uh
they can't get away from that because
they're confusing against again uh macro
world stuff with mother nature's
invisible
agents out there her secret agents
certainly we can't touch gravity you
know whatever gravity is yeah i always
show that
pencil right you let go of it and it
falls to the floor but there's nothing
here nothing here that you can see or
touch
so hopefully whatever you propose is
unseeable and untouchable because
otherwise you're not representing
gravity gravity the mediator of gravity
is unseeable untouchable okay and what
are these people talk about see and
touch and hear the same well how come
they merge or how come they don't merge
how come they go through each other
and the interesting part about all this
really is that they never ask these
questions in the context of mathematical
physics because mathematical physics
have been saying the same thing over and
over and over for decades
they talk about superposition
uh one object affecting that one over
there occupying the same space
having two different states
meaning that you know you can have an
atom vibrating at the same time not
vibrate or vibrate less and vibrate more
both in the same place
and nobody questioned that you have
particles that go through particles no
one questions that either you have one
particle at two places at once nobody
questions that either but as soon as you
say hey we have the robe and they go
through each other they say oh what do
you mean they go through each other why
did you ask the question with the
particles
it was the same situation didn't you
weren't you aware that in the last 100
years they've been saying that two
particles can be at the same place at
the same time
so please explain that before
you attack the rope
right because you i mean that's been
around for a lot longer first we got to
destroy uh what the establishment
proposes and that's been around for a
long time so i haven't invented anything
as far as untouchability and and
touchability okay
but here's the uh
continuation of that he says how do
objects push pull if they can't touch
without fusing and again this guy's
taking everything out of context he goes
back and forth between context are we
talking about quantum mechanics or rh
the rope hypothesis are we talking about
particles or ropes are we talking about
macro world or mother nature's mediators
are we talking about definitions well
what's the context here right
uh atoms uh or mediators of forces you
know
what are we talking about
and yeah
all i can tell you here let me continue
with that one and here it is here you
have two objects okay let me get these
out of the way
here you have let's let's see if we can
go step by step one more time i've done
this the other day but
apparently uh some people are hard of
learning
it's too steep a learning curve for them
okay so here we have two objects
two balls made of a single piece
each one of them so each one of that's
all that god made he just made
two spheres there white spheres in this
case
each one made of a single piece they're
not made of atoms they're not this is a
hypothetical situation by the way
because this guy's going to take this
out of context and who knows what he's
going to come up with okay
here are two spheres that's all god made
okay god's out of the picture now okay
he just made him left went to the fifth
dimension okay so this is all we have in
the universe two
white
single piece spheres
okay it's not made of anything
okay now we have those two objects now
we have uh the i got to specify that the
black stuff is space
what is space nothing what is nothing
vacuum
what is all that
that which doesn't have shape so that
black stuff doesn't have shape there is
no container okay so these two things
these two spheres are in nothing
they're sitting there in nothing they
don't move as you can see they're not
moving
there's no motion all they do is just
sit there and there's daniel we had we
have no motion yet in the universe and
again god went to
make made himself disappear so there's
no motion okay we have no motion just
two spheres do we understand the context
okay
okay now um
uh
again hypothetical situation and we're
attempting to define the word touch
that's what we're gonna try to do here
okay
okay so now god is gonna set these
things in motion okay here it is okay
and he where's his magic one and there
they go in motion okay we got that
are they touching that's the thousand
dollar question okay so god goes in
there and
abracadabra sets them in motion and when
they meet the question is have they
touched each other remember single piece
they're made a single piece okay
and uh
so here they are okay and so the
question is are they touching there
and my answer to that again is they're
not touching
they can't be touching by definition of
touch because you have separation
between them as long as they conserve
their surfaces to each
one of them it's because they're
separated or they're encapsulated in
what we call space in other words
they're not encapsulated but there's
space between those two
objects
and as long as there's space between
them they're not touching
because if there is no space between
them okay
then that means that you have this
situation which is called touch
meaning they blended into one object now
that it's a single object we no longer
have two
objects it's the only way you're going
to get that situation
pursuant to the definition of touch
okay so touch means
that's not touch why because you still
have two objects as long as you have two
objects that means each one is separated
or encapsulated if you want to use that
term in space
they're they're surrounded all around by
space we still have two objects and you
can press them harder and harder and
harder as long as there's space between
them you have no touch there is
there is not touch in that situation the
only way you're gonna have uh touching
is if you haven't blended like that they
blend into a single
object
okay do we understand the definition of
touch touch means that two objects have
become have blended in such a way as to
become one
what's the issue the issue this is a
hypothetical situation which this guy
takes out of context every time because
he says he takes it out of context
because he says well what do you mean
about atoms and we're not talking about
atoms we're talking about the definition
of the word touch
and it has to do with this situation
hypothetical situation in which we have
two objects made of a single piece that
the only way they can touch is if they
become one somehow they merged they
blended whatever however you want to
think of it i don't care but the point
is the only way we're going to have
touch is if they become one object a
single object as long as they remain as
two distinct objects
it means space
is separating you're still separating
them
and i'm not sure how else to explain
that to you okay so
if you don't understand this you got a
mental problem that's all i can say
okay just that simple
okay uh moving on here
next issue
fellow says oh well hold it uh so here
uh for real world scenario okay we're
saying that two hydrogen atoms under the
rope model the atoms are
woven
right
uh they're weaved by threads the same
threads that make up the electromagnetic
rope and so
when
the two atoms come close to each other
they can either bounce
apart
or they can
blend into each other like screw into
each other
okay and that's the situation down at
the bottom where they form the h2
molecule which is a figure eight type of
entity
and yes you can say those two atoms have
become one
and in that case you do have touch
because it's the same thread that's now
coming from one atom and going into the
other
okay do we understand that
that's
a situation in which you have
blended
shells electro uh
electric shells okay
uh electron shells
and
yeah now you can talk about touch these
two atoms have touched in real world
scenario that's the context here not the
same context as before
this individual constantly loses
uh
track of the context that's 99 of his
problem he loses track of the context
so you gotta say if you're gonna ask a
question make sure you get the context
right
spend uh i mean if you're gonna write
write a paragraph explaining the context
that you're talking you can't just say
well how about this and you mean touches
that and this and that you know you
can't you got to specify exactly if
you're talking about a hypothetical
situation if you're referring to the
definition if you're referring to
real-world scenario
what kind what is the context
okay
moving on here
[Laughter]
moving on here we have a file says lots
of questions again related to object
because again their
religions are being threatened here okay
if i can put any object i want in
gravity put the ropes in gravity and
demonstrate that gravity works on that
and
now it says if i can put any object i
want in gravity put the ropes in gravity
and demonstrate that gravity works on
them
again it's a
scarecrow okay it's a
straw man argument
in science we don't demonstrate first of
all we don't demonstrate anything okay
we don't run experiments we don't
present evidence we don't prove okay
because that's only
the intention of that is to convince to
persuade the jury that's what it's for
that's what all that evidence is for we
don't do that in science we do that in
sunday school okay that's a first issue
but then who said you can put any object
you want in gravity
where did he get this again it's a straw
man argument he says if you can put any
object you want in gravity who said that
where did you get this that you can put
any object
okay
and again does gravity act or pull on
the mediator of gravity does gravity
pull on gravity whatever gravity is
okay so so where did you get this thing
that gravity pulls on gravity
okay uh please uh prove it
okay yeah
i don't know some people have
quite quite a
struggle with all this because suddenly
they see their religion in front of
their eyes die uh
sudden death
okay another foul says nature's elastic
bands how do the elastic bands work
between atoms miles apart in the real
world
elastic bands where did i ever say that
the rope is like this rubber band hope
you can see that
no the rope does not stretch it's made
the thread is made out of a single piece
meaning there's only so much matter in
the universe
if if we were to untangle every atom if
we
untangle every rope
we would end up with a
single closed loop thread that looks
more or less like this but not like the
stretching but
think of that as a single piece okay and
so it's not it doesn't stretch
and this would be all the matter in the
universe
okay
everything from here would turn into
atoms and rows atoms and ropes all the
way down the line
okay so it's a single thread and it
doesn't stretch so this
notion that people get that there's some
stretching that gravity is some pulling
thing that it stretches no gravity is
every rope is only has tension
okay between any two atoms but the many
ropes
is what causes this acceleration because
as an object approaches another
the ropes fan out
okay so
i'm not sure how much more i can uh
clarify that i've beaten that horse to
death it's a dead horse that i'm beating
to death
okay another foul says you never
actually define rational
you just make a list of theories and say
if they are rational or not magically it
is only you
uh your theories and your
yours alone that have to be rational
see they make all these false
accusations
now here it is i did define
i i defined irrational because i think
it's uh more profitable to define
irrational than rational but doesn't
matter because rational would be the
opposite in this case and here here are
the definitions of the word irrational
okay so we did define this
criteria for defining irrational again
for the purposes of physics not for
ordinary speech okay straightforward
okay treating concepts as objects known
as reification concretization that's the
99
uh
problem with irrationality all people
who turn all these concepts such as
energy mass field
etc into physical objects they are
irrational individuals
okay
then you have the uh inconsistent
definitions or undefined words anyone
who uses the word energy mass field
force
in such a way as to treat them as
physical objects or don't define them to
begin with
you know because that's another issue
that they a lot of these words are
undefined they're declared to be
undefined by the mathematicians
themselves
the words point and line they say are
undefinable
they don't know what energy is uh
they say that they don't they have
different definitions for the word mass
etc so when you have that you have
inconsistent or definitions or undefined
words that's also irrational we cannot
follow your presentation if you're going
to have two notions of mass one is mass
the other one or say for example rest
mass and the other one is relativistic
mass meaning white you can't have two
definitions for the same word and that's
what mathematical physics has done and
all these people have just memorized all
this stuff wherever they
whatever monastery they learned in
and then the theory is inconsistent or
doesn't follow from the assumptions okay
so we do have a definition for
irrationality
uh doing what mathematical physics does
which is describing and claiming to have
explained no a description is not an
explanation explanation is not a
description
and then you have a mechanism proposed
doesn't work or cannot even be imagined
i mean you know
what space time what the hell is that
what do you mean uh work space time
again it's in usually treating a concept
as a physical object singularity like a
black hole singularity it moves uh
with stars around
you cannot even imagine a concept moving
an object
which is what these people do when they
use the words energy and mass and so on
they're they're saying the mass did it
the energy did it
what does that mean
come on
okay and here you have uh
uh super we just want to clarify that
supernatural theories are not the same
thing as irrational theories okay
uh supernatural theories that's when
they bring up all these spirits and uh
ghosts and angels and stuff like that
and usually it's the traditional
religions that use supernatural things
what's the difference the difference is
you can imagine
god
if god is an object a thing you know a
guy with four legs and nose and a mouth
well then we can all imagine
a bearded guy up there moving his magic
wand and saying abracadabra we can
imagine
that okay
we're not talking about belief here
we're talking about whether we're going
to understand the theory and the guy
says look imagine there's god okay i can
imagine god he moves his magic wand says
abracadabra creates the universe we can
all imagine that i can make a movie of
that
okay i can make a movie of that
irrational theories you can't even make
the movie
why because you're using a concept
you're saying space-time you're saying
singularity
you're saying particle and you say you
mean a little
dust a
grain of sand is that what you mean no
no that's not i mean the collapse of the
wave function
how can i make a movie of collapse of
the wave function what am i going to put
on on the screen
and that's the difference between
supernatural and irrational theories
supernatural theory is imaginable you
can make a movie of it irrational
theories you can't even do that
all of mathematical physics falls under
the second category irrational theories
and that includes uh everyone you know
uh even the dissidents like the electric
universe and uh
john chappelle uh group there
uh walter russell
tesla
nicola tesla all these people they did
all the same thing they work with
concepts they turn them into physical
objects
so they talk about charge what the
hell's charge please draw a picture of
charge what are you going to draw 1.6
times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs is is
that what charge is
charge on the electron you're talking
about an adjective
you know or an adverb at best
and you're saying uh that that does
something the charge moved
what moved the number moved the value
moved
so this is why math anyone using these
words such as charge energy
field mass
is using irrational language you cannot
make a movie
of their mechanism
and what we're trying to explain are the
mechanisms of the universe that's why
they're irrational
okay another fellow says here says do
you have any experimental physical data
confirming your rope hypothesis
my poor god
in science we do not do experiments
never do we do experiments in science
science we explain them we don't do them
okay let someone else do them let them
do it in the land of the klingons you
can do whatever experiment you want in
your basement we don't care go ahead and
do your experiment when you come to the
conference we don't want you to to
describe your experiment and say this is
what i measure we don't care about that
we want you to explain the cause what
would cause your experiment to have such
and such result that's physics but to
say that you're just gonna that you did
an experiment well yeah i i did
experiment i let go of the pencil
there yeah you know do it a second time
repeatable there it is and so we did an
experiment is that science because i did
an experiment
no you gotta explain why the cause the
the pen felt to the table to the floor
that's where you have to use your brain
but to say you did an experiment and
here's the description the pal the pen
or pencil
fell to the floor
great and what did we learn well it fell
at such and such rate
great what have we learned
i mean that's a measurement that's it
it's like saying i measured the table
and it measured one meter okay so you
measured n that was the experiment that
was the observation
uh there's nothing more
oh what is that that's science
okay and then signs we do not confirm
anything confirmed means you
are convinced of something confirmed
means you believe
you have an opinion
that's all confirmed means in science we
do not uh do opinions
that's done in religion in on sunday
school in science we have to explain
explain the mechanism physics
confirm evidence proof persuading all
that stuff
confirm is religion opinion belief
that's what uh confirmed means okay in
science we do not collect data
so i don't know what this guy wants to
collect there okay especially this thing
you call physical what do you mean
physical
experimental physical data what is
physical data
i have no idea physical again that which
has shape that's what physical means in
science
and
data doesn't have shape as far as i'm
concerned
the last time i checked okay maybe
if i drink a sufficient beer maybe data
somehow takes on a shape of some kind i
don't know but i haven't drank that much
beer at least lately
okay so no such thing as physical data
okay
physical means shape that something has
shape and data does not have shape and
it wouldn't matter if it did because
would be irrelevant
okay
in this site we do science not
mathematics and please try to learn the
basics okay yeah that's what you got to
do
okay couple more uh
issues here
paul says
uh says what strikes me is the fact that
people can do readily
can so readily believe in irrational
physical interpretations absolutely for
example why is it that the concept of
one-dimensional figures or time travel
makes sense to the layman despite being
totally irrational
we can only imagine objects
absolutely you know i mean you wonder
why people have no problem in believing
irrational stuff you know they believe
in time travel maybe because they love
the idea you know being able to travel
back in time i mean i love it too i love
um you know uh fiction
no problem i mean i enjoy it it doesn't
mean that you're going to bring that
into the real world of physics
of explanations
you know this uh time travel is nonsense
for example that's just one example but
again these people have no problem
believing in irrational theories
uh the mathematician from cambridge and
from oxford and from uh
harvard they tell them oh i got a phd
and this is this is what i'm going to
tell you i'm going to tell you that
there's something called a singularity
that moves
uh stars around we proved it
and you say what do you mean a
singularity you mean a mathematical
concept is moving a star far away how
did it do it by what mechanism
and they have no problem believing this
and say oh black holes have been proven
and here i have the proof and evidence
and blah blah blah
and they have no problem believing that
nonsense they have no problem whatsoever
believing that nonsense and
don't even dare to attack
their theory
they'll they'll burn you at the stake
okay
okay and finally one file says
there's no such thing there's no such
thing as nothing
uh yeah that is true because nothing is
the opposite of thing
okay so yeah you're right there's no
such thing as nothing good love it
but then he says the first sign of
wisdom is that i know nothing
that's a sign that you're ignorant
not that you have wisdom
uh who is it i think socrates say all i
know is that i know nothing uh
no that wasn't a sign of wisdom it's a
sign of ignorance sound is ignorance in
science we do not use the word knowledge
okay because knowledge is just belief
belief is opinion and that's what
knowledge is when you have knowledge it
means you have made your position clear
that you believe in something that's all
that knowledge means now in science we
don't care about knowledge what we care
about is explanations
in physics explanations of mechanisms
you have to explain the mechanism and
that's especially of the invisible
mechanisms that mother nature has out
there and that's when you have to use
your brain that's when we we know that
you use your brain okay
but to say that you travel through time
or that you know who knows that a
singularity moves a planet around
and you cannot explain the mechanism you
just say i believe in it because we've
proven it because it's knowledge
uh no then yeah you can really say that
all you know is nothing
[Laughter]
all you've said is that you know nothing
that you're an ignorant person
that's that's what it comes down to now
in science we do not deal with knowledge
we deal with explanations and um once
you explain something the other person
has to understand it one way of doing
that is illustrating your theory your
mechanism and everybody can see it there
in front of it in front of them you know
and watch the movie and say okay i
understand what you're proposing
doesn't mean they're going to believe it
it just means they're going to
understand it that's where science ends
what continues is
religion
with that i'll see you next time see you
then
bye bye